[Musique]
ils se sont plu pendant des années
aujourd'hui il craque
les hospitaliers réclament de meilleures
conditions de travail et plus de moyens
pour soigner correctement des soins de
qualité à nos patients on se bat
aujourd'hui parce qu on nous ferme la
paix domp si on nous a jamais la
maternité
aujourd'hui la planète inconnue c'est
pas pour yahoo
on est en grève tous ensemble tous
ensemble
infirmières aides soignants personnels
techniques et administratifs mais aussi
les médecins
on n'avait pas vu une telle unité depuis
20 ans
il ya des maladies nouvelles pour les
connaissez le sida la vache folle
alzheimer des traitements coûtent de
plus en plus cher les diagnostics ou de
plus en plus cher les gens veulent être
bien soigné
ça paraît légitime et on n'y arrive plus
donc c'est pour ça que tout le monde est
là
[Musique]